>> Just like we computed the xy position of the tile index for our atlas, we can
use the same math magic to determine what position in the worldX and worldY we
need to draw this tile. We change the numbers, right? Given the tile index, we
modulate it by the number of x tiles, and divide it by the number of x tiles
times by the tile size, to give us our pixel offsets in the world. From there,
we go back to our accelerated draw image API, that passes the image, x, y in the
source, tile size and tile x in the source. And then, where we would like to
draw it in the world X and Y? Notice that the tile size for the source and the
destination are identical here. This means we'd actually like to draw a 64 pixel
by 64 pixel atlas image, to represent a 64 pixel by 64 pixel image inside of our
world.